- I don't ever disregard the fact that
however hard you work,
it doesn't always guarantee
it's going to happen.
I would never, ever base
my career on success
or number ones or awards.
It's about being happy.
My mom and dad would never
let me put posters on the wall
because they were like
"Be you, be inspired, but
don't become anyone else."
- Yeah, yeah.
- She's an English singer-songwriter
recognized for her
unconventional musical style.
She's the first British female artist
to have six Top 10 singles
from a single studio album.
She sold over 20 million singles
and three million albums worldwide.
She's Jessie J
and here's my take on her
Top 10 rules of success.
Rule number two is my personal favorite
and I'm curious to figure out
which one you guys like the best.
And as always, guys,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down
in the comments below.
Put quotes around it as well
so other people can be inspired.
Also, when you write it down,
you're much more likely to lock
it in for yourself as well.
Enjoy!
(upbeat music)
- I don't ever disregard the fact that
however hard you work,
it doesn't always guarantee
it's going to happen.
And that's the thing that
you have to just believe.
If you don't believe in you,
no one else will even
bother to look at you
and I shoved myself for
any open mics, any gigs,
the amount of stuff I've
probably done, even up to now,
80, 90% of all my gigs for free.
Surround yourself with
people that you can trust.
people that let you be you.
Compromise, but don't ever
lose what makes you you.
Right from the heart.
Stay happy and always remember
there's always someone worse off than you.
And there's always someone
that's working harder than you as well.
When you're asleep,
there's someone graftin'
and that's what you have
to remember as well,
that for every 10 CDs you send off,
there's someone sending off 100.
Just get yourself out
there as much as you can
and film everything.
That's one thing I've learned,
I'm glad that I did footage from years ago
that when people say to me,
"Oh, you've copied so-and-so,
"you've done this, you've done that,"
I'm like, "Go on YouTube.
"Five years ago, I'm
singing the same songs
"with the same haircut."
But it's just, you got
to have fun as well.
Write it down.
Make sure you write it
down and take pictures.
Make sure it's a journey
and the journey is way more
important than where you end up.
That's what you have to remember.
If you want to be a fireman, go and do it.
If you want to be a ballet dancer,
then go and be a ballet dancer.
If you don't believe in yourself,
then no one else will believe in you.
It's so important for me
to people to understand
that I want to be an inspiration.
I was bullied as kind of
nine out of ten children are
and I want to be a role model
and I think now I'm in the
kind of limelight to go,
"It's okay,"
and it's the special
people that are bullied.
They're the ones that
have something magical
and it's something that you
can turn into a positive
and not let it eat you away.
There'll always be someone
that says, "You can't do it."
There'll always be someone that says,
"I don't believe in you."
There'll always be someone that
says, "I do believe in you,"
and there's always someone
that says, "You can do it,"
and that's the people
that you have to focus on.
However much people try and
put me down, which they do,
and they say,
"Every time I hear your song,
I want to burn my ears,"
I say, "Who's laughing now?"
I will never surround myself with people
that tell me I'm perfect
because I'm not and I don't want to be.
I'm 23 and sometimes I sing out of tune
and sometimes I lose weight
and I want to gain weight
and sometimes I say stuff that I shouldn't
and sometimes I'm going to make mistakes,
but life would be boring if you lived it
like it's going to be written in the paper
and you don't want it to be.
(audience cheering)
So I went and I said,
"Yes, it was out of tune
"and it was pitchy,
"but I've never mind
and I'm proud of that."
I like to read reviews.
I don't take them in as facts
because one person's opinion
isn't the epitome of life.
It's not the definity of my work,
but I'm very, very interested
to see what people think
because they notice things
that I may not have noticed.
I've listened to this album
70 times in the last month
so I'm not hearing things
that other people may notice.
So that's always important for me
to always try and better myself,
but listen to the right people.
I have my dream list and
I've ticked a few things off
and I add things on every day.
I think life's about dreaming big
and I think I've realized
if you put your mind to it
and a lot of people I think seem to think
I've popped out of nowhere
and I've been signed for seven years.
And there've been a lot
of times that I was like,
"This isn't going to happen,"
and it gets really tough
and Who You Are, songs like
that, made me carry on.
I would never, ever base
my career on success
or number ones or awards.
It's about being happy
and I just need to make
sure I'm happy, which I am.
So we're all good in the 'hood.
Okay, if you're a teacher at school
and there's 30 teachers
in the, what's it called?
The teacher's room, what's it called?
Staff room.
- [Interviewer] Staff room, yeah.
- The staff room, and there's
one teacher that hates you.
That's going to play on your mind.
Any normal person wouldn't
just be able to go,
"All these people like me,
"but there's that one person
that's giving me evils
"that's not giving me a biscuit."
It's a normal human thing to
want to be liked by people
that you don't know why
they don't like you,
but I've realized (laughs)
I can't keep everybody happy
and that if everyone was the same,
then everyone would agree
with the way I live my life,
but they're not and that's
something you have to accept.
And they're successful
so they should just enjoy the people
that are supporting them always, yeah.
Every body deals with
criticism in their own way.
I just have to remember
that a lot more people have an opinion,
but everyone feels the same.
Like if somebody came up to
you in the street and was like,
"Ugh, look what you're wearing.
"I hate you."
You wouldn't go, "Thanks,
lovely to meet you."
Your instinct would be like, "Wait."
But you have to remember
that there's no point in
wasting your energy on that
and one of the reasons I
honestly wrote It's My Party
was to almost verbally try
and give those people a hug
'cause the people that need
that criticism all the time
that's constantly pushing
the hate on everyone else
are the people that need a hug.
People won't know what I went through
between the second and third album,
of the fear that was impermented in me,
even though I knew I was talented,
I have to be confident in what I do
and that song was one of the first songs
that I recorded for the album
and I was actually going to
call the album Masterpiece
and I just thought it doesn't make sense.
If people hear it on its own,
it just sounds like I'm
being an absolute asshole,
but for me, I've never made it.
I've never finished my painting.
Until the day that my eyes
close and I don't wake up,
I feel like I'm still putting
towards my masterpiece
and I want to work hard
and I'm okay to say,
"Hey, I've messed up."
I do things, I say things, I wear things,
I date people I shouldn't,
but I'm human and we're
all building on something
that we hope can leave a
standing of the test of time.
And I think that that's
what that song means to me
and I've really, really
put it towards other people
that've gone, "You can't do this,"
or lied about me and said I'm
difficult or this and that
and called me a diva, when I'm not.
I'm passionate.
When people can't deal with
how passionate you are,
they attack you and that's
the same within anyone.
Just make sure that you
surround yourself with people
that you see in your future,
that were in your past,
and are still making an
effort to be in your present.
That make sense?
- [Interviewer] That's good advice, yeah.
- I think it's really important.
I think don't ever base your
friendships on the past.
Don't ever think people
should just stay in your life
because you went to school together.
Everyone changes and you grow up
and just make sure you
surround yourself with people
that are making the effort to
love you for who you are today
and who you are tomorrow.
Don't become like a cult,
like don't just like me.
Be a fan of everyone.
You can like Rihanna's
music and mine and Gaga's.
It's okay.
You don't have to be like,
"I'm a Jessie J fan
and that's it." (roars)
And my mom and dad would never let me
put posters on the wall
because they were like
"Be you, be inspired, but
don't become anyone else."
- Yeah, yeah.
- Which is why I think as an
artist I was very, very...
The one thing that I was very proud of
was when I first came out,
no one compared me to anyone.
I think you can tell
when someone's idolized somebody sometimes
and I think it's good to be inspired,
but don't become somebody.
Be yourself.
Just always be yourself.
Always.
Whatever people say about you,
whatever people believe that is true,
that isn't about you, trust me.
Life is not worth living
feeling sad and down and lonely.
Just always be true to who you are.
I'm about to give myself heatstroke
and make myself look like
a complete donut in public,
but it's all for a good cause.
Everyone's got their cameras out.
Oh, yeah!
All right, let's do dis.
Hello.
Okay, so this is, I can't even say.
This is my gorilla gig,
in my gorilla outfit,
and I'm going to sing a song
that I wrote called Stand Up.
Ready?
♫ If you surround yourself
with negative people
♫ You'll never feel settled
in or become an equal, no
♫ They'll suppress you of your spirit and
♫ Rinse you dry of smiles
♫ So reach deep and
release your inner child
♫ Yeah
♫ So stand up for the love, love, love
♫ So stand up for the
love, love, love, yeah
Ha! It's so hot.
- Thank you, guys, so much for watching.
I made this video because
Shorouk A asked me to,
so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below
and I will see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
what did Jessie J say
that had the biggest impact on you,
what lesson are you going
to take from this video
and immediately apply it to
you life or business somehow.
Leave it down in the comments below
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I want to give a
quick shout-out to Charli Funk.
Charli, thank you so much for
picking up one of my t-shirts,
actually two of my t-shirts
and posting that picture on Twitter.
I hope you're enjoying the shirts.
It looked great on you and
thank you again for your order.
So thank you, guys, again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
- Price Tag's more about
remember that when you don't have money,
you don't need to go to a five star hotel
and be in a Jean-Paul Gaultier dress
and all this to feel amazing.
Just have a little
picnic in your front room
and just remember that
your morals, your beliefs,
and the people that are
around you are more important
than how much money
you've got in your pocket.
- So there was a time when you were like,
"I don't know if this is
ever going to happen."
- Yeah, I feel like every
time I took a step forward,
like my foot broke or this
happened or duh duh duh,
I had a stroke when I was
18, just as I got signed,
and like it's always kind
of there's been moments
when I'm like, "Argh"
but nothing that's ever kind of stopped me
but I felt like,
obviously my second album
didn't get released in the U.S.
and that was a big knock back for me
'cause it just didn't feel right here,
which is fair and it wasn't my choice,
but, again, it's frustrating
because you want all the
fans to grow with you,
even if it's not what
you feel they might love.
But I just feel like
where I'm at right now,
I'm very appreciative,
even what's happened today,
I never, ever thought I would see my name
at the top of the iTunes
chart in the U.S. ever,
like so I'm feeling pretty...
- [DJ] You're feeling yourself today.
- No, I feel really like
1% of artists get to release
a third album, you know,
like only one person can sit at the top,
like for that moment,
and so when you have it,
you just have to enjoy it
and have to appreciate it.